CHRIS RAMSDALE: All right.
We'll go ahead and
get started.
So how's everybody's doing?
Enjoying the first day of
Google I/O, I assume?
Had some lunch?
[APPLAUSE]
So this is the Google Web
Toolkit and Cloud Tooling
Fireside Chat.
What we're going to do is we're
going to take an hour to
converse with some of the folks
that work on the GWT
Team and Cloud Tooling Team.
So I want to just say thank you
for coming out after lunch
and taking your time to
sit and talk with us.
The makeup of this session is--
it's kind of open and
free where it's a lot of Q&A.
It's a chance for our favorite
people, our users, to come and
talk to us and ask questions.
And we'll provide answers
and have great feedback.
So we will take a second in
the beginning to introduce
ourselves, to give you an idea
just who you're talking to and
what we're up to.
So my name is Chris Ramsdale.
I'm the Product Manager for
Google Web Toolkit and the
Google Plugin for Eclipse.
And I'll just pass it on
down the line here.
BRUCE JOHNSON: Bruce Johnson,
Engineering Director of Google
Web Toolkit.
AUDIENCE: Stand.
BRUCE JOHNSON: Joel Webber
and I started this
project back in 2000--
the mid-2000s-ish.
And then the team has grown
a lot since then.
UNNUR GRETARSDOTTIR:
My name's Unnur.
I work on the Google Web
Toolkit Team, as well.
And I work primarily on
the logging emulation.
And I did a lot of work with the
bootstrapping linker and a
little bit of work with the
CSS resources and such.
JOHN TAMPLIN: I'm
John Tamplin.
I've worked on Developer
Mode and
internationalization primarily.
RAY RYAN: I'm Ray Ryan.
I'm also an engineer
on GWT Team.
I'm [? Tech Lead of ?]
[? libs ?]
right now.
So that's UiBinder, widgets,
and that kind of a thing.
UiBinder is my biggest piece.
STEPHANIE BRUBAKER: I'm
Stephanie Brubaker.
I work primarily on GWT
libraries, most recently with
UiBinder and Safe HTML.
PHIL QUINTSLUND: I'm
Phil Quintslund.
And I work on GPE primarily,
Google Plugin for Eclipse.
JASON ROSENBERG: I'm
Jason Rosenberg.
And I've been working on
compiler optimizations and
Development Mode.
JAIME WREN: My name
is Jaime Wren.
I also work on the Google
Plugin for Eclipse.
CHRIS RAMSDALE: All right.
Thanks for the introductions.
So what I thought we would do is
give you a little bit of an
update of where we've been this
year, and where we plan
on going looking forward the
next three, four, six months.
And then check-- there was a
moderator link with some
questions that people had
already pre-submitted.
And so we'll go through
those, and then we'll
mainly open up for Q&A.
So the past year has
been a great one.
From a high level, we've started
to make releases for
GWT and GPE a bit more frequent,
which is great for
our users, which is
great for us.
It gets the cycle going.
And so it lets us get new
features and enhancements in
quite fast. We've started
down the HTML5 path.
So to now we've gone through a
GWT 2.2 and a GWT 2.3 release,
where we've had Canvas, audio,
video, local storage support
within HTML5.
And we've started to-- as you'll
see in a session that
I'm going to present
tomorrow--
we've started to think about App
Cache, and how you can use
that within your GWT
application.
So we'll talk about a new linker
that we've started to
build out that will produce
manifest files for you
automatically.
So as you can see over the past
year, we've noticed that
there's a trend obviously
with HTML5.
And we want to be
part of that.
And we think that the best
way to program for
that is using GWT.
Right?
So we'll actually provide our
own APIs on top of HTML5 APIs
to allow you, as a GWT
developer, to take advantage
of all of those features.
We've also made some cell
table and cell widget
enhancements.
And we'll continue to
do that, as well.
And so if you look at where
we're going over the next few
months, you start to see that
it kind of breaks down into
three areas.
We're going to continue
our focus on cell
widgets and cell tables.
We know that generally
developers that want to use
GWT are typically operating
with a medium-sized to a
large-scale application.
And it takes a lot to keep those
large-scale applications
efficient and fast. That's the
number one goal for us.
So what better way right now is
to introduce and continue
the motivation or the momentum
with cell widgets, and cell
tables in particular, to do that
given the fact that a lot
of these applications are kind
of business-focused.
And that doesn't mean they're
not sexy or [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
That just means that they're
handling a lot of data.
And to do that efficiently--
like that's one way your
application can get bogged down
really fast. So we think
that the investment we've made
in these cell widgets thus
far, and we continue to make
over the next three or four
months, is an important one.
So that's kind of where we
think about in terms of
application efficiency.
But then we also are very
adamant about developer
efficiency, as well.
So keep your apps running fast
and keep you as a developer
running fast. So the second
primary place we're looking at
in terms of the next three or
four months is in testing.
So we've noticed that some
internal teams as well as
external teams have had some
pain when it comes to testing.
Things like using Selenium
or even GWTTestCase.
And if you've been following
along, we've always been
trying to introduce ways
to make testing faster.
That was the motivation for the
whole MVP design pattern
was to steer you away of
GWTTestCase when you needed to
so you could function with
just vanilla JRE tests.
So now we're taking it a step
further and noticing that
like, OK, so you've adopted
this design pattern.
And you have an application that
works quite well, and you
can test quite well.
But then there's still that last
15%, 10%, 5%, if you're
lucky, of integration tests.
And for that you use things like
Selenium to do testing.
And that can be kind
of painful still.
So we continue to optimize.
And so we have some projects
in the pipeline that
will help with that.
And then finally, again, keeping
with the motto of
efficient developers, we are
currently focusing quite a bit
of effort on making Development
Mode or DevMode faster.
So it's nice because if you look
back from GWT 1.5 moving
forward, we've added a
ton of functionality.
Just to recap, I mean, we've
got UiBinder now.
We've got code splitting.
We've got a new RPC framework.
We've got an Activities
and Places framework.
And it just kind of goes
on and on and on.
Well, when you start pulling all
of those features in, it
can add some weight to
the application.
It can add some weight to
the actual DevMode time.
And so what we've seen is that
there's some things we can do
in terms of caching and smart
caching to make that faster.
And so we could take, for
example, a DevMode time of
running at 25 seconds down
to something in sub-5.
That's a high-level goal.
I'm not saying we're
there yet.
I'm just saying that that's the
way we think right now.
So those are the numbers in the
metrics we're targeting.
And so that's what's keeping us
busy for the next three to
four months.
And again, the motivation is
always efficient applications,
efficient developers.
And if we can have both of
those, then I think we've done
a good job.
A little forward looking is we
continue to evaluate HTML5
features that make the most
sense for our developers and
for our teams, as well.
And so with Canvas, it was--
well, let's just be honest.
Canvas was a fun one.
You can do a lot of cool
demos with Canvas.
I'll be honest about that.
But we've also seen that there
have been a fair number of
game developers that have
started adopting GWT as a
framework for them to develop
efficient applications, in the
games especially.
So Canvas was a smart
move there.
Audio and video tag for people
that are incorporating sound
effects and things like that.
It was a pretty easy move.
And that was good.
It was dipping our toes into
some new ground for GWT.
Because for the longest time,
we've always advocated that
you can write once and run
anywhere, any browser,
cross-browser, cross-platform.
But with Canvas, obviously,
we deterred from that.
Because we're talking like,
there's no Canvas support IE6.
And we didn't try to backfill
that with Flash or
something like that.
We just kept it efficient.
And so we ended up being quite
happy with the programming
model to give our users a way
of determining what is the
fallback mechanism for when you
don't have Canvas supported.
So given that we solved that
problem in the beginning of
the year, it opened up the door
to say, OK, now we have a
nice programming model
on our way to move
forward with HTML5 support.
And so now we're looking at
things like we had with the
GWT 2.3, we introduced
local storage.
So that's a way of caching
data inside the browser's
database, key value pairs.
And you can do it
for two things.
You can make your application
a little more snappy because
you're actually reading
from disk rather
than making an RPC.
And now actually you
can start to think
about working offline.
So if you drop a connection, you
can just queue up an RPC,
or you can queue up
a [? Read. ?]
And then with App Cache,
we pushed that
a little bit further.
So you're actually reading
everything from disk, all of
the artifacts for your
application.
And then forward thinking over
the next four, five, and even
six months, we'll think about
things like IndexedDB and a
few other HTML5 features.
We do evaluate them based on
what external teams and
internal teams need.
And the nice thing about that is
that we typically see-- as
I talk to more and more teams,
more and more external folks--
we find that there is a striking
parallel between the
teams we talk to internally
and the teams we talk to
externally.
So that's really good for us.
That happens to work
out quite well.
So the investments we make on
both sides are beneficial to
each split of our user base.
And then finally, thinking
a little further out--
and I'm quite passionate
about this myself--
is mobile web apps.
And we started off the year
hot and heavy about that.
We're doing some research, had
some requirements down,
started to formulate
a little team.
And we kind of started
scouting it around
and talking to folks.
And what we'd end up doing
is talking about how
you can make a choice.
You can do native or
mobile web apps.
And where are the benefits?
And where are the trade-offs?
And we backed off
just a tad bit.
Just because we thought we were
going to let the market
evolve a little bit and let our
customers evolve a little
bit and see what their
actual needs are.
That doesn't mean it's
off the table.
It just means that we've brought
it back in and we're
evaluating it.
But the good news is that we'll
continue to evaluate it
over the next few months.
And so we'll keep targeting a
little longer term, HTML5 and
mobile support moving forward.
But the good news is that part
of the research that we did
proved out that you can take
what we have now and what
other projects have now as
well, and you can build a
great mobile web app
that will be highly
efficient and used anywhere.
And so I have a session tomorrow
morning at 10:45
after the keynote that talks
through that and runs how to
use GWT 2.4, which is what we'll
be announcing this week,
alongside the plugin for Eclipse
and a few other things
to build great mobile
web apps.
So that's a little bit of a
background of where we've been
this year, and where we're going
over the next few months
looking into 2012.
So with that I thought
I would--
I can jump on and see
if there's any
questions within moderator.
And we can open it up for just
general discussion and have
you guys come up and
ask questions.
But actually--I should say--
actually, is there anything
else that you guys wanted
to add, too?
All right.
I think I answered
one up here.
AUDIENCE: I just was curious
what else you've done with
introducing local storage
and with your
caching in the browser?
Can you talk more about that?
CHRIS RAMSDALE: I'll take it.
So the local storage is a pretty
lightweight API over
the local storage
APIs right now.
The support we have is we
exposed the API with type
safety, which is what
GWT has always done.
So we give you type safety.
And we, right now, leave it up
to you as the application
developer to build caching
techniques on top of that.
Ray and I have had conversations
about is there a
way that we can actually hook
up local storage to, say,
GWT-RPC or RequestFactory.
And that's a very enticing
problem to solve.
But we still [? lay on it ?]
every discussion of, it really
makes sense to let the
application developer--
at least right now--
to build on top of the
APIs that we support.
So right now it's-- to answer
your question, the short
answer is that we're exposing
a thin wrapper on top of the
local storage APIs.
AUDIENCE: Hey.
We recently started using Trunk
because we wanted to
implement from file
drag and drop.
And so I'm just curious what
your thoughts are in using
Trunk, and how stable it is.
Does it pass unit tests?
CHRIS RAMSDALE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
RAY RYAN: The short answer is
everybody at Google works from
Trunk everyday.
Internally, we don't do
any kind of releases.
You create your own stability
with a release branch.
And so there is, change by
change, constant pressure on
us not to break things
and to maintain
the quality of things.
So I would be working from Trunk
if I were working from
outside of Google, as well.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Any updates on the Google RC
API and Google Map API
version 3 in GWT?
CHRIS RAMSDALE: Yeah.
So we've been having those
conversations internally about
where that support
will come from.
I think the onus lands back
on us to update them.
So we know that it's a strong
desire from the community.
And many people have asked
your question too.
And we've actually heard from
internal folks, even from some
internal sales folks, that they
get this question a lot.
So we definitely know that
it's high priority.
And we've started to identify
some folks on the GWT side
that might be able to
help out to do that.
AUDIENCE: I've got a question
about internationalization and
what the road map is
for the future.
I noticed that there was a big
commit, probably like two,
three months ago.
Could you maybe explain what the
impetus was behind that?
And what that's going to allow
me, as a developer, to do?
JOHN TAMPLIN: So when you say
big commit, can you clarify
which one you're
talking about?
AUDIENCE: Had to do
with messages.
It was like phase one of
something or another.
I can't remember it off
the top of my head.
JOHN TAMPLIN: OK.
I think you're talking about
being able to do some of the
internationalization work on the
server or at build time.
So one of the things we want
to be able to do is have
shared code that uses
the same messages.
So you don't have slightly
different formatting between
the client and server or have
to have two different
translations for essentially
the same messages.
And so what we want
to allow is have--
you have your messages
in shared code.
And then you can use those
messages on either the client
or the server.
Initially it'll just
be support for--
at build time you would
construct implementations for
the server.
Eventually--
and there's some people
who've been doing it
externally, as well--
would be able to generate
bytecode on the fly on the
server, so you didn't have to
do it all at build time.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thanks.
BRUCE JOHNSON: One quick idea
is-- if people wouldn't mind
doing it-- just say your name
and where you work and maybe
like two or three sentences
about your project.
I just think it'd be fun to
share what we're working on.
If you can.
If you don't want to, don't.
AUDIENCE: I'm Avi.
I work for Fidelity Information
Services.
They're banking software
providers basically for
Nationwide and all
the big banks.
Bank of America, they use.
So we're trying to introduce
GWT into banks.
Some of the banks already
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
based on that.
One of my struggles has been
around the look and feel.
Most of all, what goes
on hammering out
the look and feel.
And with UiBinder, it made
it a little better.
But we're still struggling
with that.
And I don't know.
It would be nice if we could
have a CSS3 style with
basically default.
Makes the application look a
little nicer so that we can
present it to product managers
because that's
what they care about.
They don't care.
So we don't want to
put in any work
beforehand to make it pretty.
Second thing was the validation
piece on the client
side that keeps getting
delayed.
I saw it was not checked
in on the release
that's part of 2.3.
What is the timeline on that?
And do you guys intend
on working on that?
Or will it be-- and one more
thing, the Activity Mapper
with the GIN, can you guys work
with that and probably
provide a sample?
Because we have like 70
or 80 activities.
And we cannot put that
in a Client Factory.
RAY RYAN: Yeah.
Most of that lands on me.
We have put in some preliminary
support to at
least get some CSS3 syntax
working properly in
ClientBundle.
Am I interpreting that right?
Oh.
I'll let Unnur address
that more directly.
We're hearing that internally
and externally, as well.
Your second question was
about client side
validation with 2.4.
It will be in the 2.4 release
at least with
experimental status.
It's a lot of work.
And it's been kind of a labor
of love by one guy who does
several things at once.
He's held it back so far
because the level of
compliance with the TCK, the
acceptance suite, hasn't been
high enough.
But now it's at the point
where teams are using it
internally, have been
for a while now.
And as of 2.4, it will be
included in the release jars.
There will be a caveat of, this
is not yet fully baked.
But it's a standard so the rug
isn't going to be pulled out
from under you.
It will simply get more and more
faithful and higher and
higher quality.
And then finally, the
boilerplate problem with
Activities and Activity
Manager is very well
understood.
That's on my personal to do list
to try to do something
about that this quarter.
At the very least, we are part
way through a sample app that
should make it clearer how to
use these things and how not
to use these things.
It will probably be GIN-based.
Even if it is not GIN-based,
it'll be run
async and async proxy.
I forget the name of
the interface.
Anyway, we are trying to catch
up with that backlog of
documentation and boilerplate
reduction.
I think that was the
three-- oh, Unnur.
[?
UNNUR GRETARSDOTTIR:
[INAUDIBLE] ?]
RAY RYAN: Right.
So there's two--
your first question was two
points, look and feel in
general and CSS3
in particular.
John LaBanca made a post
recently with a design
proposal for a new generation
of widgets.
If you use the Google search
engine to look for the term
"GWT widgets that rock," you'll
find a very specific
proposal for a new generation
of widgets that use an
appearance pattern where the
look and feel is managed by a
partner object that you have
strong control over how to
customize it, and how
to keep that going.
As those widgets get
implemented, John is taking
advantage of CSS3 where he can
and retrograding with an
adequate fallback path
for browsers that
don't provide CSS3.
But we're not hamstringing
ourselves by making sure that
everything can render
faithfully on IE6.
And then I'm going to give the
hot potato of proper CSS3
support for ClientBundle
to Unnur.
UNNUR GRETARSDOTTIR: OK.
There is not--
AUDIENCE: Stand up.
UNNUR GRETARSDOTTIR: Sorry.
I don't believe there's
full CSS3 support for
ClientBundle slated.
There may be, but I'm not
working on it right now.
The one thing we did add
was that you can--
it'll parse the double
colon selectors.
So it's a very small thing for--
but if you were trying
to use colon, colon, dash WebKit
radius or something,
that will now work.
[? RAY RYAN: You can ?]
[? work  around a lot of ?]
[INAUDIBLE]
UNNUR GRETARSDOTTIR: Yeah.
You can work around a lot of
stuff using Literal, but you
could do that before.
So sorry.
AUDIENCE: One other thing was
the printing with cell tables.
If you guys [? can example ?]
because it's a common
requirement of
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
RAY RYAN: The question there was
getting better support for
printing with cell tables.
And I will talk to the
guy most likely to
make that to happen.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My name's Chris Jones.
I work for Infogroup
Interactive, and I've been
lovingly using GWT for a long
time on an email campaign
management product.
In our development workflow,
we have a lot of different
needs for speed and fast
iterations, some of which work
well with the DevMode model,
and some don't.
So I'm wondering what kind of
items are on the road map to
improve and cache not only the
DevMode experience, but also
the straight up compiler
experience?
JASON ROSENBERG: Yeah.
So that's always an issue to
make DevMode as snappy as
possible and still allow you to
separate points and debug
and have an interactive
development experience.
So we've definitely
been focusing on
that in the last quarter.
And we'll continue in the
next quarter on DevMode
performance.
And so we are working on some
enhancements that will be
coming soon.
I can't really talk about
all the details
of what we're doing.
But one big thing will be
caching previously generated
results so you don't have to
keep regenerating things
repeatedly.
So watch this space.
CHRIS RAMSDALE: Yeah.
And to add to that, some of the
progress that we have made
is actually being able to pick
apart what actually makes
DevMode slow.
So to me, it tries to replicate
what an external
user would feel.
It just looks like it
takes a long time.
But Jason and a few others on
the team have done a great job
of picking apart that and
saying, well, here's really
where you're spending most of
your time, or where your
DevMode is spending
most of its time.
And it's been pretty
eye-opening.
And it's great because it's
gives us the bang for our buck
type of move.
So I can definitely say that
some of the [? cache in the
new enhancements ?].
To be a little more specific,
we're looking at things like
code generators running
all the time.
Which is something we've
added a lot to.
Like Ray and Bob and various
other people have--
some of the magic about GWT--
if you want to call it that--
is the ability to run code
generators behind the scenes to
do a lot of the boilerplate
that you don't need to write.
Well, running those every time
can be a little inefficient.
It gives you a great experience
because you can
always get your app
up-to-date.
But if you're running all the
time, and you're running 25 of
them-- just throwing a
number out there--
that can get a little timely.
So they have looked into--
well, one of the ways of
caching is obviously if you're
generating code, and that code
has not changed, you
should cache it.
And if you can read it from
disk, it becomes very fast.
That's kind of where our
mind is right now.
And I think we are actively
trying to get those into the
2.4 final release.
I didn't mention this
in the beginning.
The 2.4 release that we're
talking about tomorrow is
going to be a beta release.
And then we're looking to do
an [? an RC uniphoner ?]
release with two, three weeks
everywhere in between.
So that's the timing we're
talking about.
So yeah.
I've been talking to Jason and
Eric and a few other folks
about what we can do to
get that in there.
So yeah.
Keep an eye on it.
And we'll definitely
have some updates.
AUDIENCE: Are there any plans
to bring those types of
optimizations into
the compiler?
RAY RYAN: Jason, do you want to
say something about that?
JASON ROSENBERG: Yes.
Yes.
So speeding up the compiler
process as well
is a part of that.
It may not be quite as dramatic
as the improvements
we've seen with DevMode.
But we definitely have some
targeted ideas about the
compiler as well that we've--
BRUCE JOHNSON: So we've picked a
couple of internal apps that
are just massive apps.
And so those are pretty good.
They really stressed
the system a lot.
And Jason and the other guys
he's working with are actually
doing something.
And I want to plug Speed Tracer,
too, just real quick.
If you guys have not
seen Speed Tracer--
actually would you mind raising
your hand if you have
heard of Speed Tracer before?
OK, good.
OK, good, good, good.
So that might be useful.
You work on-- is it Yesmail?
Is it?
Is it still called Yesmail?
OK.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Switched names, but yeah.
BRUCE JOHNSON: OK.
Cool.
So if you haven't, Speed Tracer
is great for that.
And what Jason and Toby and Eric
did was they basically--
was it a separate build
with Speed Tracer?
JASON ROSENBERG: Yeah.
So we found a new way to use
Speed Tracer just to monitor
the DevMode and compiler
process internally.
So we instrumented the internal
GWT code to generate
a Speed Tracer output file that
we can then visualize.
And it's really been
eye-opening.
We've been able to see where
the slow points are in the
process and really
target those.
And we're happy with
where we're headed.
BRUCE JOHNSON: It's so cool
because you know normally with
Speed Tracer, you see a graph of
where things get slow, and
then you see the event list
of what all happens.
Imagine the same thing except
what you're seeing is what is
happening inside DevMode,
or what is
happening inside the compiler.
So it's not actually about
the app running.
It's about the tools
themselves running.
And so we jokingly call
it Tool Tracer.
But it just reminded me though
that maybe we should make it
somehow available if
it's not already.
So that Chris instead of trying
to describe in this
format what's going on, if you
could just send a dump of what
you just experienced, and other
people did the same, we
could maybe see patterns.
I don't want to set expectations
too high on
whether we'll be able
to prioritize that.
But it would certainly add a lot
of detail so that we can
do our best to make
it better for you.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
JASON ROSENBERG: Yeah.
You can come talk
me afterward.
I can try to help
you with that.
AUDIENCE: Cool.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My name is
[? Steven Haberman. ?]
I work for [? Gazoo. ?]
We do online advertising.
And yeah, so the new cell
widgets sound all sorts of
really cool.
Cell tables also really nice.
And I get why the [? perf ?]
benefits are great.
But they're kind of not
really fun to use.
And I think could be
much more so if--
I've heard rumors of UiBinder
support for cell stuff, which
I think would be terribly
awesome.
It would make my life
much easier.
Do you have any comments
on that?
CHRIS RAMSDALE: Stephanie.
RAY RYAN: Yes.
We would like to add cell table
support to UiBinder.
We'd like to have more
engineers too.
But that's on the short list
of very next things.
In the meantime though, if you
look at GWT Designer, it
already has tremendous support
for cell table.
GWT Designer is now
included in the
Google Plugin for Eclipse.
And it gives you this nice
little canvas where you can
drag out your table and drop
columns onto it and specify if
it's at this column or that
column or the other column.
And it'll just get all of that
code laid out for you in the
first place.
So in the meantime, please
do look at that.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My name is Steven Cohen, and
I work for inRESONANCE.
We do software for independent
and private schools.
And first thing I want to do
is I want to thank the GWT
team because three years
ago my boss had
me evaluating tools.
And I showed him a couple of
early videos back in 1.4 days.
And that's the reason why we've
converted everything
we're doing webfacing to GWT.
And we're still in the process
of migrating some of our
back-end from an
old LAMP to--.
So I wanted to thank you all
because you've made my life in
managing that flow with the
other developers I work with
so much easier.
Got two questions.
One is about java.util.Date.
Yeah.
I figured it would
get a laugh.
Just to sum it up for anyone
who doesn't know because
there's so much chatter out
there on what's the
best thing to do.
Currently you're using
deprecated code, deprecated
calls if you want
to access that.
And everybody's got
their own opinion.
But I would love to
hear something
definitive from you all.
The other thing is about DevMode
in Chrome on the Mac.
Again--
and it's gotten so
much better.
It still will time out
here and there.
And I'm just interested in
having a better understanding
of why, as opposed to when
will this be fixed.
But I'd really like
to have a deeper
understanding of what's different.
And that might actually be
something that's more
appropriate to ask to the Chrome
team than here since it
looks like it's an issue with
how Chrome works with it.
But I would love to hear
anything that you have to add.
JOHN TAMPLIN: OK.
So about java.util.Date, the
main problem is that the
replacement in the JDK Calendar
still has some
limitations.
And the infrastructure simply
isn't there in the browser to
provide all the functionality.
So we would have to basically
download a whole bunch of
extra code and data to
emulate Calendar.
What most people are
using is Joda-Time.
And there's a GWT emulation
part of that.
There's been some requests
internally to basically
support Joda-Time
built into GWT.
But that complicates things
with an external project
trying to keep up to
date in GWT and in
the external project.
And I've also heard that they're
planning to take
Joda-Time or something very
similar in a later JDK.
My guess is at that point we
would basically provide
support for it directly
in GWT.
The question about
Chrome speed.
The basic problem is
there's object
identity inside the browser.
So if you pass an object in
JavaScript to Java, the same
object twice, Chrome actually
gives the plugin two different
NPAPI objects.
And so in order for us to make
that work so it actually
preserves the identity, we
actually have to put an
attribute on every object that
goes over to Java, which means
we have to go back across to V8
to look up that attribute.
And so that slows it down.
There's also an object identity
problem going the
other direction, which we
actually can't work around.
But it turns out that it only
matters in a few cases.
So that's the basic
performance issue.
There's been a couple of bugs
open on Chrome for a while.
And my understanding--
the guy who's worked with
them isn't here--
but my understanding is that
they don't really want to
spend much effort on fixing
NPAPI because it's on its way
out, being replaced by Pepper.
And so they would rather spend
the effort on making sure it
worked properly in
the new API.
CHRIS RAMSDALE: But we have a
couple of teams internally
that are really focusing
on Chrome and apps
that work on Chrome.
And so while John is right that
they are looking towards
Pepper as the future, NPAPI
is here, and it's now.
And so there are a couple of
teams that are feeling the
same pain internally.
And not to mention the fact
that it works faster on
Firefox than it does
on Chrome, I
personally don't like.
But that's just me.
So yes, we're actively
looking into it.
And as John--
he did a great job describing
the problem.
It's not an easy one.
Patching Chrome is something
we've done.
We've made commits to
WebKit, as well.
But it's not just a
quick fix problem.
And so yes, we're
looking into it.
It would be tough to give you
a timeline on it right now
even if you had asked.
RAY RYAN: Let me ask the
audience a question about the
date issue.
And I'm making no promises here
at all, but I'm curious
about the reaction.
If we were to actually write
a minimal GWT date object,
something that would work client
side and server side,
that we could emulate
efficiently without providing
every last bell and whistle,
but that you could also use
server side for that kind of
convenience, would that be
well received or would
that just be
in the wrong direction?
[APPLAUSE]
OK.
Some applause and about 1/8
of the hands went up.
It's an interesting signal.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My name's Gary Miller from a
startup called Sumwise based
out of Sydney, Australia.
We're on the sandbox.
Come get Tim Tams. No one seems
to want our Tim Tams.
I'd like to say thank
you to the GWT team.
Been a big fan.
Been using it since 1.3 and then
quickly swapped to Trunk.
Just a question, something that
I haven't seen around.
Last year at I/O, Headless Speed
Tracer got mentioned.
I'm interested in profiling so
the question extends into
lightweight collections and
then on to testing.
So just what's the status?
CHRIS RAMSDALE: So
the status is--
OK, so I'll take the lightweight
collections one.
So the status on lightweight
collections is we've done a
large amount of research on
where are you actually seeing
the increase in size, and where
do you see the increase--
slowness basically.
So like where do you get a code
size bloat, and where do
you see slowness when
you use them?
And what we found out right
now is that the--
you really have to have a
perfect storm of basically
implementation practices to
get the benefit of this.
So for example, if you're
using HashMap--
across your application you're
using HashMap with strings and
then some with just
objects as IDs--
then you actually end up
downloading a whole bunch of
code that you don't actually
want to use.
Or if you use--
I think it was--
HashSets versus HashMaps.
But the point is that you had
to have exactly the right
combination to shave off a
certain amount of code.
AUDIENCE: Can I add
one thing to that?
We're using Google
Collections.
Fantastic on Chrome.
Runs like a dog on Firefox.
CHRIS RAMSDALE: That one I--
RAY RYAN: You're talking about
the Guava code runs badly on
Firefox, but not on Chrome?
AUDIENCE: Well, it's
a profiling issue.
So profiling is hard.
That's the one thing that
I think it might be.
But profiling just takes so much
time to set up and run
and tear down that you kind of
do it every now and again.
So Headless Speed Tracer would
probably help with the
profiling stuff on the Chrome
side of things.
I have no idea how you could
integrate Firefox profiling
into a continuous build.
Big app.
CHRIS RAMSDALE: Yeah,
I don't have--
so in terms of Google
Collections and when the
slowness of--
I don't have an answer off
the top of my head.
But we can go back
and find more.
AUDIENCE: Specifically
a profiling issue.
I mean, just how-- best
practices on profiling.
Where are we at with
that type of stuff?
OK?
Offline.
CHRIS RAMSDALE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Yes, hello.
I'm [? D.J. Jarra. ?]
I'm leading a team of
60 GWT developers.
So I have two questions.
The first is about
compilation time.
So we are building very big
applications with GWT now.
So each time my developers lose
one minute in front of
the screen, at the end of
the day it's 60 minutes.
So it's a lot of time for us.
So will you work on improving
the completion time?
And the second question is about
the Channel API from
Google App Engine.
So will you provide a wrapper
for this API?
RAY RYAN: Could you repeat
the second question?
AUDIENCE: There is a Channel API
in the Google App Engine.
Will you provide a wrapper,
a web wrapper for it?
RAY RYAN: For the compile speed
question, I think we
answered that already.
We're trying to make
it faster and we'll
keep making it faster.
There are very big teams inside
of Google too, and they
all know our phone numbers so.
CHRIS RAMSDALE: I have a
question about that.
So we prioritize in making
DevMode faster and then making
the compilation faster because
we think that the way people
usually use GWT is by simply
using DevMode.
So you run it, and then you do
a refresh in the browser.
Is that not the case
with your team?
Are you guys actually doing
compiles each time?
AUDIENCE: In fact, we use
continuous integrations.
Each time people commit some
change, you have to start a
compilation.
And if it's a big project,
it takes a lot of time.
CHRIS RAMSDALE: So if end
up seeing errors in the
continuous integration, you
might be off by a few commits
or tens of commits or
something like that.
Is that your point?
You see a build breakage, and
you have to go back and figure
out where it happened because
it might take
hours to do your compile.
OK.
RAY RYAN: That's a
very good point.
We are working on it.
And we do get both
messages a lot.
DevMode needs to be faster.
The compiler needs
to be faster.
The compiler is harder because
it has conflicting goals.
We're trying to squeeze
your binary down
as tight as we can.
And that takes more time.
And at the same time, you want
the compiler to run faster for
obvious reasons, and there
are trade-offs.
And the other question you asked
was about the App Engine
Dev Channel--
CHRIS RAMSDALE: Channel API.
RAY RYAN: Yes, Channel
not Dev.
The word channel was involved.
We're not doing anything
specific
to that at the moment.
There are examples of GWT code
exposing that and using it.
I don't think it's terribly
hard to roll your own.
The example I'm thinking of--
did that ship as part of the
App Engine demo?
AUDIENCE: The demo last year was
the go-go Android dancers.
Their source code
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE].
So just look at last
year's I/O.
RAY RYAN: From the audience,
Gary tells us that last year's
I/O had a demo involving
go-go--
AUDIENCE: Dance dance robot.
RAY RYAN: --go-go dance
dance robot.
The code for that
use channel--
it is--
CHRIS RAMSDALE: Oh.
Where's Toby?
AUDIENCE: Will you release a
specification of this API?
Because some people want, for
example, to build a Java
wrapper for this API.
RAY RYAN: We should.
It's not on the list
at the moment, but
it should be there.
So clearly we should
get to it.
In the meantime, I would
look up Toby's demo and
extract from that.
And I expect he will have
put good code around it.
CHRIS RAMSDALE: We did have some
internal teams looking
into it too.
They were doing kind of
an experiment with a
collaborative application
using GWT.
And we love App Engine.
We really do.
And they used the Browser
Channel to actually do it.
And they weren't completely sold
on it was time to pull
the trigger on creating
the APIs around it.
Now this was, arguably,
five months ago.
So what they were doing was they
were seeing a little bit
of latency in the updates, or
they might miss an update here
and there, which pushed them
to go a different route.
So maybe it's in our best
interest to follow up with
them too and see has
the API solidified?
Does it feel solid?
Is it time to actually bump that
up in priority to say,
yeah, instead of doing IndexedDB
support for HTML5,
let's go do Browser Channel
because it just makes sense.
JOHN TAMPLIN: Some people were
also looking at the idea of
having an abstraction that would
work on either Browser
Channel or Web Sockets.
So it would be one common
API to use with both.
One question about your
compilation speed.
Are you compiling just one
permutation or all the
permutations?
OK.
RAY RYAN: The answer was one.
AUDIENCE: OK.
My name is Brett Connolly.
I work for Intuit out
of Athens, Georgia.
And the primary product that I
work on is an administrative
platform built around
the Liferay portal.
And I've seen a ton of questions
on the GWT Developer
Forums, on portlet support.
We currently use GWT Dispatch to
make our RPC requests up to
our portlet resource handlers.
And it works fine, but there
are some issues with
maintainability when it comes
to upgrading GWT.
And there are some core pieces
that we are missing.
Is there any plans to actually
bring in portal support,
portlet development
support into GWT?
BRUCE JOHNSON: Yeah.
So we don't really have
a stock answer
to that exact question.
So I'm just going to tell you my
opinion about it, which is
that you have to sort of pick a
level of how much out of the
box functionality do you want
to provide when you do
something like GWT.
And if we go too high, then it
becomes sort of a special
purpose thing.
And it might be good for
you, but not as good
for some other people.
And so we sort of don't
want to go that high.
We're just like it's great as
long as all you want to do is
portlets or portals.
But then if you go too
low-level, then it doesn't
provide quite enough
functionality out of the box.
We try to strike a sweet spot so
that it's possible to kind
of get a lot of value out of the
box for there to be other
projects that can spring up that
you can use a third-party
library or framework
based on GWT.
And we've seen that work well in
other sort of subject areas
on top of GWT--
open source projects that
take advantage of it--
and it raised the level, if you
use GWT as the base plus
that project as sort
of a layer on top.
And so for something as specific
as portals and
portlet support, it feels to
me like that's a little bit
higher level than we would tend
to do out of the box.
So I guess I would just maybe
turn the question around to
the audience and say, are you
guys aware of any good
projects that try
to address this?
And if there is, that it'd
be good for you to know.
If there's not, then that might
be an opportunity for
someone to start a project
of that sort.
Does anybody--
anybody else wanting portal
type support, portlets?
It's a really tough call to
know exactly what to do.
It's easy for us though to say,
it should be easy to just
build the layer yourself
or just use iFrames or
something like that.
Of course, I know that's not--
that may not be a very
satisfying answer though.
AUDIENCE: And we built a
framework that actually works
and works really well.
But like I said, there are
a couple limitations in
maintaining during upgrades.
It's hard.
And having that in the
core would be great,
but we're fine now.
BRUCE JOHNSON: So I
wanted to say--
I want to just describe how we
think about it so you'll get a
better feel for sort of what
you probably can bank on us
doing versus you can say it's
probably less likely that we
would do it.
So if there are specific
lower-level plumbing pieces
that would be needed for you
to build your own support,
that's something that we
probably would do.
So code splitting, for example,
is the kind of thing.
It's kind of high-level.
But it's also kind of low-level
and generic.
Other things like
that might be--
let us know if you
think of those.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Well, I appreciate the answer.
RAY RYAN: Have you given
any thought to open
sourcing your platform?
AUDIENCE: I've thought about
it, but within our company
there's political things that
have to go into contributing
to open source.
Makes it difficult.
BRUCE JOHNSON: Now you can say
the GWT team said they didn't
have any plans to do it so--
AUDIENCE: Right.
So we do it ourselves.
So thank y'all.
AUDIENCE: My name is
[? Jay Gindin. ?]
I'm with [? App 2. ?]
We do cost transparency for
large IT organizations.
So when you're talking
about enterprise
software, that's really--
that's what we are.
But along those same lines,
enterprises tend to use IE
more than anything else.
And unfortunately some of them
are even still stuck on IE6.
And so my question is
kind of a follow-up
on the earlier question.
What plans do you guys have--
Speed Tracer is great,
and it helps.
But when we get into a real
issue, it often turns out that
the tools that are available for
Chrome are great, but they
don't actually give you any
insight into what's
happening for IE.
So do you guys have any thoughts
or plans to help out
even though it's kind
of competitors.
But it's really-- it's us who
are using GWT to build the
apps for our customers.
CHRIS RAMSDALE: Yeah.
That's a great question.
So sometimes there are--
I'll be honest about this--
there are some legal
constraints that we have with
doing certain products that
would work with Microsoft.
But that said, we have found
that Microsoft actually has a
pretty good set of debugging
tools that you can use
alongside their browsers
that will like--.
So for example, I think
Speed Tracer is great.
And when it comes to profiling,
it's one of the
best. But Chrome Dev Tools
are really good.
And Firebug is really good.
And Microsoft has their own
versions, too, that we've
actually used.
I know Joel--
I've seen it running on Joel's
machine quite a few times.
AUDIENCE: Their dev tools have
gotten better, but they still
kind of suck.
Just like if you look at Speed
Tracer, it's very detailed and
tells you, hey, you're spending
like half a second
rendering this widget.
And OK, you can usually
extrapolate and say, well, if
I can make it better in Chrome,
it's going to be
better in IE.
But just because it's really
good in Chrome doesn't mean
that it's also really
good in IE.
And so you just have
no visibility.
Right?
The profiler that's in the
Microsoft dev tools just
doesn't give you a whole lot.
And what we found was there were
times where it just would
hang and just do nothing.
And basically your only recourse
at that point was to
go kill the browser.
CHRIS RAMSDALE: And you saw--
I mean, hanging in terms of you
wouldn't actually be able
to hit a break point
inside your--
if you ran it in DevMode
for instance?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, their dev tools
would just basically
wind up hanging the browser.
You just couldn't get any
information out of it.
CHRIS RAMSDALE: That
is unfortunate.
AUDIENCE: So if there's hooks
or anything that you can put
into GWT, which it sounds like
maybe the other tracer tool
you were talking about a few
minutes ago might go some
distance towards helping.
CHRIS RAMSDALE: Yeah.
That's interesting.
So the format for what Speed
Tracer can consume is out
there for the public to see.
And so you could theoretically
drop traces out of your
application.
This is not a trivial thing to
do, but it's possible that you
could actually drop traces out
of your application that could
be consumed by Speed Tracer.
AUDIENCE: All right.
AUDIENCE: Chrome Frame might
be a good tool to use also.
CHRIS RAMSDALE: Yeah, actually
you raise a great point.
I was going to ask this based
on your question.
So if I can ask everybody
else here a question.
I've heard over the past few
days that there still are a
lot of IE users.
I've heard quite a bit that IE6
is going away, and you're
seeing a lot of potentially
your end-users using IE8.
But it still doesn't totally
help us out because I'd love
to see people get to IE9, which
starts to give us the
ability to really push
the open web.
But how many folks are still
having to support IE6 and--
go ahead.
We'll ask one at a time.
So, OK.
That's down from last year.
And then how many-- it's
a two part question.
How many people have actually
tried to get either their
company or their end users
to use Chrome Frame?
How many have had success?
OK.
All right.
If you have any--
we'd love to hear back with the
stories on how this works.
Because we like to pitch it, but
it's still a tough thing
to do because if
you get past--
I'll be honest--
if you can get them to start
thinking about it, as soon as
you say, we have to install a
plugin to run the application,
they kind of freak
out a little bit.
AUDIENCE: So my question is
about optimization that the
compiler could potentially do.
I'm working on a file size
constrained device, so the
ultimate generated code needs
to be as small as possible.
So permutations kind of hinder
that when you get into seven
or eight different languages
and three or four browsers.
So the other thing I wondered
about is I'm also only using
the client side functionality,
so having interface compatible
code for Java is a little
overkill on
the JavaScript side.
So I wonder if there was
any plans to do kind of
micro-optimization at that
point or file system type
optimization.
CHRIS RAMSDALE: Don't think
there's anything happening
right this second.
Optimizations we're doing,
we're talking more about
DevMode and compilations.
I would suggest that there was
a talk given last year by Ray
Cromwell that can find on
YouTube that details just
about-- it's called Faster
Apps Faster--
and details just about every
possible compiler flag you can
throw at the GWT compiler
to reduce your overall
compilation artifacts as well
as compilation time.
So that might be a good start.
And that's what I have to say.
BRUCE JOHNSON: I just wanted
to add a couple things.
What kind of device are
you talking about?
AUDIENCE: I'm not sure that
I can say at this point.
But we're talking--
I'm looking to get our client
down to, say, five megs.
BRUCE JOHNSON: OK.
And how big is it now?
AUDIENCE: Right now, I only
have a few pages, and I'm
already up to about
three or four.
BRUCE JOHNSON: Is that
[? obfuscated? ?]
AUDIENCE: Yes.
BRUCE JOHNSON: So something
sounds weird.
AUDIENCE: Well, I've got
30 permutations so--
BRUCE JOHNSON: Oh, oh.
You're talking about not
per permutation.
You're talking about--
AUDIENCE: Not per permutation.
I'm talking overall.
CHRIS RAMSDALE: You
don't have to go--
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
limited.
BRUCE JOHNSON: It's limited
disk space, so to speak.
Flash or whatever.
AUDIENCE: Limited disk
space, correct.
BRUCE JOHNSON: So for that I
would say, do you actually
need those permutations?
Are you just getting those
permutations out of the box?
Is one question you should--
AUDIENCE: No, I've actually
trimmed it down to the
necessary languages that
we need to support.
Now I have seen that you can
have a monolithic kind of
internationalization
happening.
But that seemed kind
of overkill.
BRUCE JOHNSON: Well,
you can, but--.
So there's this idea of
soft permutations.
And I think that's one.
Are you aware of that idea?
Soft permutations?
AUDIENCE: No.
BRUCE JOHNSON: OK.
Do we have some good threads
on that on the groups about
soft permutations?
I'm trying to give him
a reference for--
because nobody will remember
anything we say right this
second probably.
RAY RYAN: There's a
wiki page for it.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
BRUCE JOHNSON: There's
a page for it?
There's a wiki page for
soft permutations.
So what you can do is basically
compile it all into
one JavaScript file and then
do a runtime decision.
So every GWT.create
call right now--
or not every, but typically--
that's where the
code fans out.
It's where the universe splits
into different JavaScript
compilations.
But soft permutations collapses
it so that it's
actually a runtime decision.
It actually stays inside the
same JavaScript file.
However, there is going to
ultimately be some limit as to
how small you could make
it even best case.
But you do avoid some
duplication of, like the UI
code wouldn't get repeated
in each permutation.
With soft permutations, you have
the UI code plus the sum
of all the additional
code for each of
the localized versions.
AUDIENCE: OK.
As I recall, I read something
about that.
And you lose like number
formatting or currency
formatting on the
locale level.
BRUCE JOHNSON: You might want
to say something about that.
JOHN TAMPLIN: So for
the [? ITN ?]
side of it, there's runtime
locales, which doesn't get you
different translations, but it
gets you runtime switching
between country-specific
formats.
So you can have just a Spanish
translation, and then you
still get all the different
date-time formats, currencies,
et cetera, for each different
country that you're using.
The soft permutations can
be used on top of that.
I'm not sure how well that's
going to work for you.
But if you have just one
browser, you should be able to
get it down to only the
different languages for your
permutations.
Is that what you already
have done?
AUDIENCE: We're actually
supporting three browsers at
the moment.
JOHN TAMPLIN: Yeah, most things
in GWT, we felt like
the disk space is cheap, and so
if we can make things run
faster by using more space on
the server, that's a good
thing to do.
You can turn some of that off.
Like for example, inlining
images and things like that.
BRUCE JOHNSON: Yeah, I guess
the sort of roll up thought
there is, look at a
compile report.
Are you familiar with
how to do that?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, definitely.
BRUCE JOHNSON: Look at
the compile report.
Consider soft permutations.
And double check how your
resources are getting inlined.
Maybe something is happening.
If they're using data URLs,
they're getting inlined into
the script, and then that's
getting duplicated across
permutations.
That can get really big.
So the answer is probably
already there in your data.
Do you have like a million
plus lines
of Java source code?
AUDIENCE: Getting up there.
BRUCE JOHNSON: OK.
You should be able
to work this out.
It's just a matter of cleverly
arranging the switches and
compile settings probably.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
One more quick thing
before I go.
How many of you all hang
out in the IRC Channel?
Any of you?
CHRIS RAMSDALE: I think you can
always find Kelly Norton
there, actually.
AUDIENCE: OK.
I was just curious.
I don't know how many of the
people that hang out there
were actually GWT developers.
CHRIS RAMSDALE: There's
a [? K. Norton. ?]
RAY RYAN: Not too many of us.
One or two people pop in
every now and then.
We are starting to pay more
attention to stack overflow
these days.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
CHRIS RAMSDALE: So we've
got 3 minutes and 16
seconds and 4 questions.
Let's see how fast
we can do this.
AUDIENCE: Quick question.
My name's Spencer Gibb.
I work for the LDS Church.
Question about support for
custom UiBinder XML handlers.
RAY RYAN: Yes.
We still don't have any plans to
open up the UiBinder Custom
Parser API just for fear of
the support nightmare.
However, some recent changes
that you might not be aware of
have dramatically reduced
the need for that.
Have you found the UiChild
annotation?
AUDIENCE: Uh-uh.
RAY RYAN: So, UiChild lets you
annotate method on a widget to
be called for child widgets.
And so it used to be that if
you wanted to have widgets
inside your widget, you
had to implement the
Has Children interface.
You now have much, much more
control over that.
You can decorate as many methods
as you want to accept
children of specific types.
You can put limits on to how
many of them you will actually
accept and that kind of thing.
So the combination of that and
the UiConstructor and UI
Factory Annotations that give
you some control over how
things get created and the
existing bean parsing
conventions of Set Property
and so on.
Internally, we've been finding
a lot fewer people asking us
to write new custom
parsers for them.
I can't remember the last one
that actually got written.
It doesn't help you retrofit
existing widgets.
But if you are running your own
widgets, you've got a lot
more control than you
used to have.
AUDIENCE: Great.
Thank you.
RAY RYAN: We should probably
document that.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm [? Xi ?]
[? Wang ?]
from Solium Capital.
We let people exercise their
stock options, view reports on
their stock options, et
cetera, all via GWT.
So we've had a lot
of success there.
My question is about
direct-eval RPC.
Does it still have a future?
And if not, were there issues
with that approach that
resulted in it being
a dead end?
RAY RYAN: The guy who knows the
most about that was smart
and hid today.
But deRPC is all
but deprecated.
Really, we should just put the
deprecated label on it.
CHRIS RAMSDALE: Hence, D-E
in front of the RPC.
RAY RYAN: That's right.
It is the de-RPC.
It didn't live up
to its promise.
We didn't get as dramatic an
improvement as we expected.
And that improvement is less and
less as browsers get more
and more modern.
The code base is a nightmare
to maintain.
The two big problems that it
solves, the ability to
serialize final fields, there
is a patch that continues to
be this close to fixing that
problem for regular GWT RPC.
If you look at our
[? write build ?]
tracker, you'll see that it
keeps getting woken up again
as a particular person
gets poked on the
shoulder about it.
It will land soon,
I'm certain.
The other problem that
it solved was--
CHRIS RAMSDALE: Are you
talking about the
serialization?
RAY RYAN: The slow
script problem.
And I don't know that we
really have a good
answer for that yet.
Yes.
I've been reminded that part of
the reason that we're less
concerned about that is that
we have in the meantime
introduced an alternative RPC
system, the RequestFactory,
which doesn't have any of these
problems and is also
more opinionated than GridRPC in
how one should structure an
RPC layer properly, and keeps
you out of a lot of the
problems that GridRPC leads you
into with ballooning code
size as you serialize things
you didn't mean to and that
kind of a thing.
We don't have it explicitly on
our road map to try to make
those two RPC systems converge,
but conversations
like that are ongoing.
But to the question you asked,
deRPC, not so supported.
CHRIS RAMSDALE: Can we-- do we
have time for-- should we--
Nope.
We have to cut to.
So we'll be hanging around.
I know we have two
other questions.
Please feel free to come
say hi and ask us.
But I appreciate everybody
coming out.
And I hope this was
beneficial.
We thoroughly enjoyed it.
Thanks a lot.